elle avait tout d'une grande malgré son
petit gabarit et son petit numéro né il
y a 40 ans la 205 a toujours son fan
club àzoule Frédéric bdan Antoine Larche
c'est bien tu as réussi à retrouver un
CR la dernière fois tu l'avais pas
Damien et Anthony sont des passionnés de
la mythique 205 qui vient de fêter ses
40 ans bien plus que des collègues il
travaillent tous les deux chez
stellantis savezou ce sont des amis
fiers de ce sacré numéro je suis 73 donc
c'est mes voitures préférées quand
j'étais gamin et voilà depuis quelques
années j'ai c'est ma 2è en c'est ma 3è
ouais et là j'en ai encore une autre à
la maison en cours de rénovation on a
profité de cette journée pour pouvoir
ben emmener les enfants faire découvrir
un peu ce qu'on faisait sur le site
parce qu'il y a quelques secteurs qui
sont ouverts donc ça permettait de faire
une pierre de coup d'exposer son
véhicule et puis de pouvoir partager
avec avec le fiston quoi au cœur de
l'usine les 205 et d'autres voitures
d'exception le directeur du site a même
eu le temps de déposer sa 205 sur le
parking je suis né la même année les
premières qui ont été construites sur
sur Mulous c'est une voiture de cœur ça
reste la voiture emblématique de la
marque Peugeot en 15 ans ce sont plus de
5 millions de 205 qui sont sortis
jusqu'en
1998 des usines de socho et de Mulous en
Franche compé la 205 a même son rally
qui part de la haute zone direction le
Maroc avec un détour sur les routes du
département pour se mettre en
appétit donc on a pas mal de 205
inscrits mais aussi de voitures
mythiques de prestige qui vont parcourir
cet après-midi 113 km sur les terres
saunoises au sein de notre beau
département avec des énigmes à résoudre
on les envoie vraiment trouver la pierre
percée par exemple une source d'eau
chaude dans la forêt la fête des 205 se
poursuivra demain du côté de
frotterlilure pour la centaine
d'équipage qui prendront la direction du
Maroc du 26 octobre au 3 novembre
prochain pour cette 20e édition de
l'afric
Ared